mais on est dans dans la nouvelle salle
qui a été créée de toutes pièces c'est
qu'elle n'existait absolument pas donc
là c'est quand même une un peu un tour
de force parce que on est posé en
fait le gradinage est posé sur le sol
des anciennes caves de l'ancienne
librairie une salle flambant neuve pour
le cinéma d'arrêt d'ESS des lancour qui
en compte déjà deux ciné fait pet neuve
et sa réouverture est très attendu tant
le chantier a traîné des problèmes
d'Amand c'est qu'on a localisé de
l'amante supplémentaire qu'il a fallu
enlever donc ça veut dire des délais en
plus et cetera après on a trouvé de
l'eau dans une des salles en bas enfin
dans la salle du bas sous la dalle donc
il va fallu traiter ce problème plus des
problèmes avec certaines entreprises je
dis bien certaines pas toutes euh parce
qu'il y a des entreprises avec
lesquellel il y a aucun problème euh qui
proposaent des solutions qui étaient pas
les bonnes le cinéma devait réouvrir en
mai dernier son directeur compte à
présent sur une réouverture début
février à son grand soulagement il y a
une pression terrible pour tout le monde
c'est-à-dire que évidemment pour les
entreprises qui sont qui sont sur place
pour les gens qui suivent le dossier au
niveau de la communauté d'agglomération
parce que pour eux c'est très compliqué
la surface du cinéma a doublé près de
1000 m carrés pourront désormais
accueillir le public en plus des films
proposés en version numérique des
rencontres et coloques devraient venir
compléter la programmation le prix un
ticket devrait rester inchangé 6 € au
tarif plein montant des travaux plus de
300 100000
€